Der 1. FC Köln steht trotz einer deftigen 0 zu 3 Niederlage in Magdeburg weiter auf Platz 1 der 2. Bundesliga und will zurück ins Oberhaus. Der 1. FC Nürnberg hingegen schleicht sich so unbeirrt von internen Querelen mit zuletzt drei Siegungen allmählich an die Aufstiegsplätze heran, gehen der FC und der Club am Ende sogar zusammen hoch. Das bespreche ich nun mit Fadi Kiblavi von den Nürnberger Nachrichten und Dennis Vom Trotzdem hier Podcast.
Let's go.
Jetzt nun im Programm.
Der Rasenfunk.
Lagerheim fliegt vorbei und der Ball ist im Tor. Und Augsburg ist oben. Russies zu kurz Abwehr, lang genug für Willi Landgraf. Wagner, Martin Wagner.
Und das an's Turno.
Markus Kurt aus dem Bivou.
Alexander Schur!
Der Blick auf andere Ligen.
Okay, das wäre nämlich noch eine Frage gewesen, wie schwer diese Trennung dann den Clubpersonel trifft. Dennis, du meldest dich hier ganz vorwärtlich. Ich schieß gerne rein.
Ja, ich hätte mal eine Frage an Fadi, die mich so ein bisschen umtreibt. Ich weiß damals, als der Transfer von Finn Yeltsch bekannt wurde und dann durchsickerte so acht bis zehn Millionen für einen 18-jährigen Zweitleger Spieler, da sind bei uns in der internen Chatgruppe die Emotionen sehr hochgekocht. Ist Finn Yeltsch dieses Geld wert? Also ist er ein Spieler, wo man sagt, der wird mal irgendwann 20, 30, 40 Millionen wert sein? Ist das jetzt ein gutes Invest von Stuttgarter Prof. B.s. oder ist das wieder so eine Alex Verle, haut das Geld raus, Aktion?
Es gibt solche Stimmen und solche Stimmen in Nürnberg. Ich möchte noch mal an meine Kloseeinschätzung vom September erinnern. Also es ist mit Vorsicht zu genießen, aber ich bin tatsächlich anders als manche meiner Kollegen, sehr überzeugt davon, dass Finn Yeltsch irgendwann nochmal, auch das ist wieder ein bisschen zynisch, wenn man dann sagt, er wird ein bisschen mehr wert sein, aber er wird auf jeden Fall ein Erstligaspieler beim VfB Stuttgart werden können. Also er ist für sein Alter wirklich enorm reif, hat natürlich noch Fehler drin, ist ein auch durchaus offensiv starker Innenverteidiger. Das war jetzt in der letzten Zeit in Nürnberg auch immer so, dass die Innenverteidiger immer mal wieder auch im defensiven Mittelfeld im Spielaufbau aufgetaucht sind und so was. Also ja, ich glaube, lohnt sich für den VfB. Ich bin mir angehört zu haben, für den Sommer war der Transfer abgemacht, dann hat der VfB ja einen Innenverteidiger verkauft und dann wollten sie Finjelcz. Jetzt schon haben hat es für den ersten FC Nürnberg noch mal ein bisschen finanziell einträglicher gemacht, aber ja, ich bin überzeugt von Finjelcz. Bei mir, selbst meine Podcast-Kollegen sind da nicht ganz der Meinung zumindest einer, aber ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, guter deutscher Innenverteidiger wird es.
Das glaube ich auch tatsächlich. Aus der Ferne beobachtet habe ich das Gefühl, einige Szenen gesehen zu haben. Die sind schon außerordentlich gut. Jetzt haben wir ausgemacht. Datenbasiertes Scouting, sehr gutes Verhandlungsgeschick. Das sind so zwei Komponenten des, ich sag mal, Ausbildungserfolgs des ersten FC Nürnberg in der jüngsten Zeit. Eine weitere Komponente ist ja aber auch die Akademie. Also wir haben Finjelic, wir haben Gian Oso, Nathaniel Brown. Und jetzt gehen diese Saison ja auch Talente, neuen oder den neuen Entwicklungsschritt. So Leute wie Jan Reichardt, Nick Seidel, Tim Janisch, Dustin Forkel kommen so langsam in den Profikader gerutscht. Wer ist in der Akademie dafür verantwortlich zu machen? Denn jahrelang hatte man das Gefühl, Nürnberg hochgeschätzte Akademie, aber groß rauskommt, tun sie dann woanders. Das hat sich jetzt so ein bisschen gedreht. Wie habe ich das Gefühl?
Ja, also man muss es auch das ein bisschen differenzieren. Ich glaube, Michael Wiesinger leitet das Nachwuchsleistungszentrum. So heißt das hier in Nürnberg noch, bild ich mir zumindest ein. Da war vor kurzem mal ein Namenswettbewerb. Weiß ich nicht genau, ob der Name jetzt schon offiziell ist, aber egal. Michael Wiesinger leitet das. Ich glaube, er leitet es gut. Man muss aber differenzieren. Jeanne Ouson, Brown, Yeltsch, das waren jetzt drei absolute Ausnahmetalente, bei denen ich mir nicht so sicher bin, wie viel der Verein da jetzt wirklich dafür kann, dass die da sind oder.
Die brechen einfach durch, weil sie so gut sind.
Ja, exakt. Und bei denen, die du jetzt sonst noch genannt hast, Seidel, Joachim, Jan Reichardt ist ein solider Zweitligatorwart momentan, spielt so seine erste Saison jetzt bei den Profis und so was. Da muss man erst mal abwarten, ob da jetzt dann ähnliche Entwicklungssprünge. Bin ich eher skeptisch. Ich glaube, das waren jetzt wirklich mal drei Spieler, bei denen man das große Glück hatte. Die kommen jetzt gerade retten dir ein bisschen die Finanzen, retten dir natürlich auch für eine oder zwei Saisons dein Spiel ein bisschen, den sportlichen zumindest verhindern sie den ganz großen sportlichen Misserfolg. Ob das jetzt so weitergeht, bezweifle ich momentan noch. Was glaube ich schon so ist, ist, dass Nürnberg für junge Spieler anderer Vereine ein bisschen attraktiver geworden ist. Das passiert dann immer so, wenn mal ein Verein zwei, drei Spieler gut verkauft hat oder nach oben gebracht hat, dann erzählen da immer an allen Standorten die Leute, ja das war vor kurzem noch irgendwie so die Erzählung in Fürth. Wir sind der Ausbildungsverein Nummer eins und die Leute bieten uns alles an, was irgendwie Talent besitzt und so was. Das ist vielleicht, da hat auch Jens Kastrup tatsächlich, um auf den nochmal zurückzukommen, auch eine Rolle gespielt, weil der einfach in Nürnberg eine gute Entwicklung genommen hat. Aber ob das in Nürnberg so weitergeht, da wage ich noch zu bezweifeln, dass da jetzt ständig irgendeiner rauskommt aus der Jugend, der dann ein Jahr später für 10 Millionen irgendwo verkauft wird.
Verstehe. So und welche Bedeutung hat das jetzt alles für die allgemeine wirtschaftliche Lage des Vereins? Wie ist Nürnberg derzeit aufgestellt? Weil man weiß, Nürnberg einer dieser chronisch klammen Clubs, aber trotzdem kann man da ja mal ein bisschen differenzieren, wie sich das in den letzten Jahren entwickelt hat. Und gibt es beispielsweise infrastrukturelle Projekte, die Geld brauchen? Also steht da auch irgendwas an in nächster Zeit?
Nürnberg ist immer noch ein finanziell klammer Club, auch wenn Reppe und KC. Alexiou, als sie uns nach der Transferphase dann mal zum Gespräch eingeladen haben, um ihrem Stolz-Ausdruck zu verleihen, gesagt haben, dass sie zumindest jetzt nicht unbedingt verkaufen müssen nach den Einnahmen, die sie da jetzt generiert haben. Aber der Club...
Das sagt man natürlich auch gerne, das treibt ja die Preise auch hoch.
Exakt, so ist es. Und da geht es tatsächlich in erster Linie, glaube ich, jetzt um Caspar Jander, den der 1. FC Nürnberg wahrscheinlich eher nicht für 6 Millionen Euro ziehen lassen würde im nächsten Sommer, sondern dann schon in die Yeltsch-Dimensionen rein gehen wollen würde. Ansonsten ist der 1. FC Nürnberg nach wie vor arm. Das ist einfach zu lange zweite Liga jetzt. Zu oft falsche Entscheidungen von Hacking und Treppe, auch auf dem Transfermarkt, wird dann immer ein bisschen so behauptet, das fehlende Geld liege daran, dass man einfach einen zu großen Verwaltungsapparat aufgebaut hat oder auch beibehalten hat in der zweiten Liga, weil man sich immer noch als Erstligis gefühlt hat. Ich glaube, das ist das geringere Problem verglichen mit all diesen vollkommen danebengegangenen Spielzeiten zuletzt und auch Transfers und sowas. Es ist geplant, ein neues Stadion zu bauen.
Wie weit ist man da?
Max Morlock-Stadion ist tatsächlich in die Jahre gekommen. Man fühlte sich sehr weit. So gefühlt hat es sich an, hörte es sich an, es würden mehr oder weniger morgen die Bagger kommen.
Ist das nicht immer so? Das war in Berlin ganz genauso.
Bis dann vor kurzem eine Agentur noch mal die Pläne ein bisschen nachgerechnet hat und dann feststellen musste, dass in der einen Kalkulation des 1. FC Nürnberg knapp 100 Millionen Euro fehlen würden und der Klub dann 20 Millionen oder noch ein bisschen mehr Pacht im Jahr zahlen müsste. Also das hat das ganze Projekt jetzt ein bisschen ausgebremst, sowohl bei der Stadt als auch beim 1. FC Nürnberg. Ist man jetzt sehr bemüht, die Menschen davon zu überzeugen, dass es trotzdem zeitnah weitergeht, aber wohl mit einer etwas abgespeckten Version.
Zwei Fragen dazu. Erstes Thema Standort und zweite Frage Finanzierung. Das sind ja immer so auch die zwei großen Fragen. Also weiß man, wo es stehen soll? Was passiert mit dem alten Stadion und wie finanziert man das?
Es soll es wird ein Vollumbau. Also steht da, wo jetzt das Max-Morlock-Stadion steht. Und Finanzierung war immer so 30 Millionen, soll der 1. FC Nürnberg beisteuern, wie auch immer. Und 30 Millionen die Stadt und der Rest eben über Investoren und Sonstiges. Ich war immer schon ein bisschen skeptisch. Wir alle wissen, wie schwierig es derzeit ist zu bauen und dann so ein Projekt hinzustellen. Der 1. FC Nürnberg zahlt tatsächlich oder die Stadt zahlt tatsächlich sehr viel, um das Max-Morlock-Stadion, das einigermaßen marode ist, in Stand zu halten. Das war so auch das Argument in der Stadt, im Stadtrat immer, dass das Geld kann man sich auch sparen und dann baut man eben gleich ein neues Stadion. Es ist sehr spannend, wie es da weitergeht. Es war dann immer vom 50.000 Zuschauerinnen-Stadion die Rede, jetzt gibt es wieder welche, die sich auch plus 40.000 vorstellen können. Es sollte ein Hotel integriert werden, auch das ist jetzt wohl eher mal erst mal wieder gestrichen, nachdem man diese kleine Finanzlücke entdeckt hat. Bleibt spannend, wird tatsächlich in den nächsten Wochen und Monaten ein Thema bleiben, rund um den 1. FC Nürnberg. Meine Skepsis ist nach wie vor da, wie das funktionieren soll. Aber was man immer so hört, ist es muss funktionieren und mal gucken.
Man kennt ja viele Vereine, die sich an so einem Stadion-Projekt völlig verhoben haben. Deswegen sollte man ja wirklich vier und fünf Mal drüber rechnen.
Ja, exakt.
Zurück ins Hier und Jetzt. Nürnberg steht derzeit auf Rang 9, fünf Punkte hinter Platz 3 und 2. Schielt man jetzt auf den Aufstieg? Wohin soll der und wohin soll der Klub mittelfristig sich entwickeln? Wie ist da die Kommunikation der Verantwortlichen, sowohl von Klose als auch dann eben den höher liegenden Gremien?
Erst mal die höher liegenden. Es war ja war der Plan, in Nürnberg eine ruhige Saison zu spielen.
Das ist ja schon mal hybris in Nürnberg.
Exakt. Hat man einerseits geschafft mit Platz 9 irgendwie, aber andererseits den Sportdirektor rausschmeißen nach der erfolgreichsten Transferphase. Das ist der Vereinsgeschichte spricht dann wiederum, spricht wiederum dagegen. Wir hatten schon eine Trainerdiskussion, eine Torwartdiskussion in Nürnberg. Es gibt gerade mit Mai hier im Relien Spieler im Sommer erst gekommen. Ein Angreifer aus Aserbaidschan, der jetzt gerne schnell wieder weg will und so was. Miroslav Klose hat am Sonntag tatsächlich nach dem Spiel gegen Ulm gesagt, dass seine Mannschaft auf dem Weg zu einer Spitzenmannschaft ist. Alle anderen bleiben da noch zurückhaltend. Wer den 1. FC Nürnberg ein bisschen kennt, der weiß, das Umfeld, das von Olaf Reppel kürzlich mal als das schwierige Umfeld bezeichnet worden ist.
Klassiker?
Sieht sechs Punkte Rückstand auf den 1. FC Köln und ist davon überzeugt, dass es in drei Spieltagen spätestens, dass der 1. FC Köln dann überholt ist. Also die Euphorie wird gerade ein bisschen größer. Hängt sehr viel vom Spiel gegen die Hertha am Wochenende, am Freitag ab. Tatsächlich sieht man aber auch, man hat jetzt fünf der letzten sechs Spiele gewonnen, es ist immer noch erst neunter, könnte schwierig werden, dann nochmal ganz oben ranzukommen. Und das wäre dann tatsächlich, damit werden dann auch alle rund um den Verein einigermaßen fein.
Und mittelfristig, wie plant der Club? Also es gibt ja immer dieses typische, wir wollen zu den Top 25 Deutschlands herauf.
Ich wollte sagen, ja auch wir auf der 1. FC Nürnberg will zu den Top 25 in Deutschland. Was ich auch wirklich für eine riesen Quatschansage halte, aber tatsächlich ist es genauso von den Verantwortlichen kürzlich erst wieder gefallen. Ja, der 1. FC Nürnberg muss irgendwann wieder in die 1. Liga aufsteigen aus finanzieller Not. Ganz einfach, ob das gelingen kann. Diese Saison macht ein bisschen mehr Hoffnung, aber da gab es auch in der Vergangenheit immer mal wieder so eine Spielzeit, wo man dachte, okay, das ist auf einem guten Weg und in der nächsten wird dann alles wieder zerschmettert. Man muss mal gucken, Joti Hacielic Sioux ist jetzt in seinem ersten Jahr Sportvorstand, war vorher wirklich nur in der Verbandsarbeit tätig, kann man noch nicht so ganz einschätzen, wie der arbeitet. Es hört sich immer alles ganz gut an. Man muss mal gucken, wie es jetzt ist, wenn er dann mal für eine Transferphase wirklich allein verantwortlich ist oder mit demjenigen oder derjenigen Nachfolgerin von Olaf Reppe dann vielleicht.
Vielleicht. Wir werden das mit Spannung verfolgen. Dementsprechend bleibt mir eigentlich nur noch zu sagen, vielen lieben Dank Dennis, vielen lieben Dank Fadi, dass ihr eure Vereine hier einmal komplett ausgeführt habt. Man könnte noch ewig weiterreden, glaube ich. Also sowohl Köln als auch Nürnberg bieten Stoff ohne Ende. Aber vielleicht kommt es in dieser Saison nochmal dazu. Wenn beide oben groß angreifen, dann kommen wir in der Ligatur gar nicht dran vorbei. Bis dahin spiele ich hier schon mal das Intro ab. Das läuft ja immer schon eine Weile und möchte an dieser Stelle dann noch sagen, dass ich natürlich darauf hinweisen möchte, dass ihr supporter und supporterin werden könnt. Dieses wunderbare Podcast geht dafür auf rasenfunk.de/supportersclub. Podcasts habe ich dieses Mal keine zu empfehlen, aber wie gesagt, Fadi, Dennis, vielen lieben Dank und dann einfach bis zum nächsten Mal. Ich freue mich drauf.
Tschüss.
Der Rasenfunk hebt von euren Beiträgen.
Vielen Dank.